haha
if you dare hey look a little cut look
out Shrek he got a piece it's a cat
donkey come here little kitty kitty
kitty come on
come here little kitty
[Music]
oh did I miss no
you got them
now again
pray for Mercy from
puss
I'll kill that cat
[Music]
okay foreign
that is nasty
what do you reckon we should do with
them I see we take the sword new to him
right here give him the Bob Barker
treatment
please I implore you it was nothing
personalized in your I was doing it only
for my family my mother she's sick and
my father lives out of the garbage the
king offered me imagine God and I have a
little brothers
Fiona's father paid you to do this the
rich King see
well so much for Dad's Royal blessing oh
come on straight don't feel bad almost
everybody that means she wants to kill
you gee thanks
ah
maybe Fiona would have been better off
if I wear some sort of Prince Charming
hey that's what the king said
oh uh sorry I thought that question was
directed at me
Shrek Fiona knows you'll do anything for
her well it's not like I wouldn't change
if I could
I just I just wish I could make her
happy
hold the phone
happiness
teardrop away
donkey think of the saddest thing that's
ever happened to you oh man where do I
begin well first it was the time that
old farmer tried to tell me for some
magic beans I ain't never got over that
then this fool went off and had a party
and he had all the guests trying to pin
a tail on me then they all got drunk and
stopped beating me with a stick on
pinata pinata what is the pinata anyway
no donkey I need you to cry yeah well
don't go projecting on me I know you're
feeling bad but you gotta let your own
[Music]
hairy little licking sucker
what is it on is it on
this is Fairy Godmother I'm either away
from my desk or with a client but if you
come by the office we'll be glad to make
you a personal appointment have a happy
ever after
oh
are you up for a little Quest donkey all
right that's more like it Shrek and
Donkey on another Whirlwind Adventure
Ain't No Stopping Us
stop okay
join the club we've got jackets on my
owner I am obliged to accompany you
until you have saved your life that you
have spare me mine I'm sorry the
position of annoying talking animal has
already been taken let's go Shrek
Shrek
[Music]
Shrek oh come on donkey look at him in
his Wee Little Boots you know how many
cats can wear boots honestly oh let's
keep them say what
ah oh listen he's putting oh so now it's
cute oh come on Donkey lighten up
lighten up oh I should lighten up look
who's telling who to like
hey isn't we supposed to be having a
fiesta
[Music]
black cats
gonna make me fall
[Music]
do New Sensations new kicks in the kind
of light she's got a new addiction for
every day at night
[Music]
[Applause]
shine
[Music]
[Applause]
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
Fiona
you should not be here
purse
[Music]
you've got to be kidding me
feed me if you dare first what happened
to you you got so far
fancy do I know you well where's your
hat where's your belt
your wee little boots boots for a cat
put your Puss in Boots
maybe once
but that is a name I have outgrown
that's not the only thing you've had
growing hey I may have let myself go a
little since retirement hanging up my
soul was the best decision of my life I
have all the cream I can drink and all
the mice I can chase
eh I'll get him later oh purse what have
I done to you you've gone soft
well I need to get brushed twice today
look it's not too late to fix it all you
have to do is help me get a kiss from
Fiona what are you doing hey can I help
you with something well I know how
stressful mounting a rebellion can be
rallying the troops planning the attack
so I brought you a little something to
ease the tension
a gift basket you're welcome so let's
see what you got
Heart-Shaped Box of slugs
skunk scented candle but this really
isn't the time what's this coupons let's
see good for one free foot massage a mud
facial oh and here's one good for one
free kiss let's cash it now look I don't
know what this is all about but I'm
trying to run a revolution so unless you
have Rumpelstiltskin's head in there I
suggest you take your gift basket get
out of my tent and go make yourself
useful
wow
you're right
I am sorry
I was just trying to be friendly no hard
feelings
an apologetic hug
and a quick kiss goodbye
ah wait is that mistletoe I see
hey Shay I'm a baby's cute or do they
make people feel uncomfortable where do
we find that guy could it be true
of the years of Bremen pamperi made me
soft don't be silly
now who's a pretty kitty I am
put up your Turks
[Music]
very well if it is to be a dance fight
then I will choose the night dance fight
you to the death
[Music]
how dare you do the litter box on me
look
[Music]
when you feel me
thank you
[Music]
awesome
[Applause]
fear me
[Music]
foreign
you hit me in the head with a guitar
you're a woman oh
amateur
paying back San Ricardo told being rich
[Music]
you me yeah yeah baby
one two one
there is one word for you kitty
softballs meanwhile I know you have
quite a reputation with the ladies Mr
frisky two times I've also been known as
there
fairy lover
but that was before I met you no you
don't know me I'm not who you think I am
I'm all about the score come on
and tell me all you care about is the
gold
[Music]
Partners
do not fall for his animal magnetism
stay focused
please
so I have been thinking these softballs
that when we go our separate ways we can
go our separate ways to get
together
you have to go now you do not have to
push me away anymore you can trust me
but give it up for the legends of San
Ricardo Humpty and puts we dead
I'm calling it a night guys Diddy stay
up with us no I feel like
terrible coming on
okay yeah have fun with that
we should give her some privacy
never thought we would get to hear
that all we went through
to pull this off together
it is good to have my brother back
yeah
sure is
well we have a big day tomorrow
really exciting stuff
depressed
good night
can Nesta
you died
doctor please
relax I
laugh at this
you see and anyway I am a cat I have
nine lives and how many times have you
died already
uh I don't know I never counted I am not
really a math guy you know gato take it
easy doctor let's see here there was the
running of the bulls in Pamplona
[Music]
Hold Us
I guess it's not your night fellas
I'm telling you I can't always lands on
his feet what
no version but doesn't need a spotter
watch
[Music]
no need to pull into part this will
revolutionize trouble watch
uh excuse me does this have shellfish in
it yes sir
something too high I am a master of the
baking watch
[Music]
and then there was the giant today
so what is that like uh before
that makes eight poos you are down to
your last life my prescription no more
Adventures for you you need to retire me
retire Are You The Village comedian as
well
is there any safe place you can go any
special someone you can rely on in this
moment of need
I am pushing boots loved by one and all
ER I mean uh how could I possibly choose
this is the address of Mama Luna she is
a cat fancier always on the lookout for
a new lap cat you will be safe there lab
cat I am no lap cat doctor I am pretty
boss not anymore Barbers orders I mean
Doctors Orders
and remember boost
death comes for us all
treat you really got to work on your
bedside manner
[Music]
ah what is that
who's that
he's here for me
close
I've enjoyed the chase cartoon
but I think we've reached the end now
you and I
you're gonna take the cowards way out
run away to more lives
are you gonna fight
pick it up
come on pick it up
[Music]
what's the matter lives flashing before
your eyes
[Music]
fear me if you dare
this is
[Music]
thank you
the end
movie
[Music]
you really gotta stop losing that
say hello to my gatito blade
[Music]
pick it up
I know I can never defeat you Lobo but I
will never stop fighting for this life
[Music]
you're ruining this for me I came here
for an arrogant little Legend who
thought he was Immortal
but I don't see him anymore
live your life missing boots live it
well
you know we will meet again right
[Music]